paint the situation headshot is the new
movie starring ayahuasca Lassie
each eek I don't know wise I never
learned how to pronounce his name I
looked it up earlier I don't know if I
did it right
I liked the raid I like the rate to a
lot this is from the directors who did
the movie killers and one of them they
they co-wrote with a total grade and
they did one of the VHS two segments one
of the yeah one of the mobile brothers
works a lot with Gareth Evans resentence
Edwards Edwards now Gareth Edwards as
Godzilla Gareth Evans is the rate yeah
he hopes up so one of the motor others
works with him a lot and then this is
his other collaborator as the mo
brothers anyway this watches I read the
plot description Nuri sounds about Jason
borne before I did it sounds exactly
like the Bourne I accepted just I love
whatever it ends on was like who sweet
sweet revenge join screenplay infinite
film
[Music]
konna toko tomako
la mattina come on escape aegisub Nadia
oh I cut again I'm not gonna go
huckle manga Da Capo Genji pop-up window
over new I can tell you coming all right
I will have a second
[Music]
whoa whoa oh [ __ ] that was crazy
oh man Indonesia don't need you what are
you guys doing Oh see Watson whoa let's
uh let's just have to play without yeah
go for a little long let's just talk
about this I actually haven't seen the
films that these guys are like mainly
known for not seeing them I've only seen
the raid in the raid - this looks
[ __ ] like awesome yes it's amazing I
mean this very simple premise yeah very
simple premise so this guy Rama has you
know he has amnesia
his lady who's also his nurse I guess I
don't know maybe maybe he thought of a
situation I have a bond you know
while there or maybe he was he may be
like the reason he has amnesia so these
people were attacking him and then he
survived whatever attack that happened
well no I think it's it that you know he
washes up somewhere and then they you
know yeah but back see how I shine up
from well I don't know but I feel like
that happened before this movie
why is he washing up did someone shoot
him and then he like they thought he'd
just die in the water but then he washes
up on shore II so why maybe this is all
connected well this is all before he
joined Treadstone this is all before you
purchase actually I've had like it
doesn't actually look like a part isn't
it what's really cool about the look of
this film is that there seems to be real
like tension and real villains well the
first half of the trailer seems like
it's communicating like we're gonna take
the drama of this actually kind of
seriously and tell a story about you
know these people you know it seems kind
of like a people movie in the first half
know it's seen yeah it seems like it's
very engaging towards like the emotions
of these characters so when the violence
kicks in it makes it like that much more
intensified yeah it makes it look like a
different kind of film instead like
we're going to jump to the
action right away it's like we're gonna
watch you know this this bond grows so
the one it's taken down you just want to
see [ __ ] a man what's his name the
main actor eco wise he was like cut in
the first raid yeah then he had a child
in between the raid 1 & 2 so kind of put
on some weight when he was in the raid 2
yeah now he's back to being [ __ ] sexy
super sexy super sexy sexy the route 2
way to go ayahuasca so tricky names a
new name it was I'm gonna learn a lot
about yourself through the magic of
hallucination but that [ __ ] shot dude
were there all that's tiny hallway and
they're just shooting at each other this
all rebels oh that's horrific
I've been in that situation I have to
and let me tell you that's tricky well
it's a tricky one
if you survive you're very lucky guy I'd
only do it one time that was like
supreme screaming not so I did at one
time same thing here I decided it wasn't
for me yeah see I was that guy way in
the back I learned way and I let
everyone else die and then I shot hello
head in this shot people are shooting
but I don't see anyone falling over I
know that's so brief though but still
you think like someone will fall over
maybe it's an unfinished shot just for
this prize is a second the fighting does
look really cool I mean it's got that
that Bonebrake [ __ ] love kind of
violence that we wanted there to be a
same time it doesn't look like it's shot
exactly like the raid I know it's a
different director yeah yeah it still
has its own style because you know like
these guys did like films like killers
and we're involved in VHS - yeah so they
know how to create a real like sort of
tension and horror element to their
films and that's what I feel like the
first half of his trailer was giving me
was like okay we characters though I
could probably care about as when I
watch this film at the same time there's
a there's a real level of tension not
just about like let's get to the [ __ ]
mum action sequences well yeah and it
has that sort of like the rain movies
are more of like an action film whereas
this seems like it's taking the revenge
movie and amping up the action from
there like blending the two together cuz
it seems like a very sort of revenge
movie plot like you know yeah it's a
very tender place and then something
goes horribly wrong no it seems simple
but it's into action now just looks
[ __ ] crazy though like yeah that's
existing about the action in the mood
this actor ain't just from the first two
rain movies I've seen like this guy
there's someone who I
and easily he like even though he
doesn't really do these characters are
like backed up with a sane amount of
dialogue he still knows how to create
these protagonist characters who seem
vulnerable kind but when they fight
thoroughly yeah he's Jason Bourne maddie
is matt damon an indonesian almost like
a more mild-mannered Jason Bourne
because even in the parts of the raid
were the right to and stuff where he's
just at home like I kind of believe that
still I wasn't like eyes guys gotta get
at home no he seems like a real human
being yeah he does it and he's a good
actor I think like he's he has an
earnest presence he stole the show in
the force awakens totally stole the show
really utilized him to their best you
know we heard that they're gonna get the
rey guys involved in the new Star Wars
movie we thought hey a bunch of crazy
new martial arts Jedi action ya know
they gave us something better
thirty Seconds of them showing up in
weird costumes that's really 101 that's
all I wanted an all take want to make it
only so either enhance the fight scenes
don't use your skills to update this
franchise now yeah let's get them in
there for what we really want it that's
just a teaser trailer so we can't really
talk too much more about it but yeah I
can't wait for this movie to come out
looks like a pretty good trailer looks
like a really cool yeah you get the
whole you get the plot basically
communicated now when I watch the movie
I get to learn who these characters are
why give a [ __ ] about them this doesn't
seem like a red band trailer even though
there's a pretty violent moments Jesus
van eyes Boulevard Oh see what's cool
about this trailer to me like I like
this kind of trailer even if it's just a
to you like I like this approach cuz
this is showing me like yeah here are a
few things that I they're definitely
gonna happen in this story and here's
the tone and here's what to expect to
the fights you know like it just kind of
tells me what to expect without giving
me too much so now I want to go see it
and I want to know what all this is
leading to and what it's all about what
it's all for like don't like I like when
they they give me a reason to wonder
what it's about instead of telling me
what it's about yeah like here's the
situation here's what it feels like and
I like that so I'm excited to get to see
that you know headshot
or if you need a channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject
John is Oh facebook.com slash and he's
also on facebook.com slash the real
rejects take care